more mind games to me an astronomers got
480 grenades they gonna need the window
are they gonna use a smoke nade the
window and there could be two kills come
out here [ __ ] this could actually be a
nightmare here they come the ass both
kills landing oh my goodness this is
gonna be a lot of fun guys killing
someone in csgo with a gun is fine
killing someone and see us go with a
knife oh that's pretty good
killing someone and see us go with a
grenade well let's just say when you
unleash that package of fire and
fragmentation and your kill food lights
up in response well it's a very special
feeling the first part of this video is
gonna be all about those HD dunks those
molotovs those made stacks and those 200
IQ plays where grenades play a key role
but didn't necessarily deliver the death
blow the second part of this video is
gonna be when utility goes horribly
horribly wrong oh and when it goes so
wrong it goes right it's a decoy Frank
over oh my god so whether it's an H II
dunk or a perfectly time Molotov we
thought it was about time to give you
the very best grenade kills fails and
funny moments from csgo that tried to
remedy those sort of things and make it
a little less hardcore in terms of AK
spirit again they tried to avoid the
nades and then they take a hundred and
fifty damage ladies and gentlemen you
ever seen anything like it
walk out as well get him out of here
this could be the ticket for a Sharla's
these grenades could do all the work for
them three of them going over the world
exist one on cribs everybody's catching
fire twist Goes Down and there it is
they roasted Muriel alone in the site
that's like one they don't even consider
the fact that he could still be in the
corner because they have to pay for so
long with his patients it catch them
slightly off but fortunately he'll burn
[Applause]
they're so good with utility on the in
strongest side they live before the
organ I'll be here after New York that
hey chief good show something oh my
you're leading oh my god rush me again
and that's why Dan you don't rush me -
IH dr. aim of course he couldn't he
doesn't give me s Quatro became attorney
what the [ __ ] throw ball it's all about
bouncing straight down me inside up off
dog spreads quite well actually because
la la is actually being tagged by it's
forced all the way and it's very well
throwing rain and that's perfect because
rains flames hits and this is just a bit
of a standoff now between Smiths and
flush it still sitting further back on
the site I'll try to evacuate now city's
gonna find a surprise in for him he
doesn't actually get the notes go but
the drop I made from fluff stuff is
gonna end up finishing them off that's a
style kill if I've ever seen one
[Music]
this is a very awkward buy from them but
look at all the mall times they have
five molotovs they have better just like
napalm this site like fire bomb like
Vietnam let's look at this this where do
you go slap it so we're gonna fall to
major that's dispatch each aw here and
they make their way under the same
avoidance players tag very low that
needs enough to do it their boats gonna
go down shortly Aegis slam dunk of the
century with the on finds ah somebody's
treated by Nav
[Music]
do you think you did it on purpose I
think you did it on purpose
grenades again Oh what happened oh it's
a Sunday roast I don't even know what
you put on a Sunday roast in America any
I think it's a barbecue get some pork on
there get some beef strips and crispy
strips get it all cheap a Lurie this
America after all Henry oh my god never
have we seen anything like this it's so
rare and you can see oh my god that boy
Stan some sexy chick in action way to
the bomb not again
he runs towards uma just wants to die
but with this world did everyone die to
the boy every single person died to the
ball you know Jenny will probably know
anyway oh yeah boy stur firing at all
like hey say something again oh you're
just noticing the way I'm talking to you
now you see it turns out I am an
American citizen after all there's the
whole back team one just a couple of
seconds tonight of their capability to
set up I'm gonna fire the shot I think
it seemed like it's clear but meanwhile
Stanislaw has the closest approach she
can move out take down MCH oh look at
that
nicely done uses the nade to bounce the
a K over to himself so he doesn't have
to cross in the open that's smart stamp
that's Tigers what Keenan poor in this
game so far his off I mean we focused on
Burks with the AWP to control against
Guardian but it was at this moment he
knew he [ __ ] up oh that's beautiful
Fryeburg turns him right back into it
for a pawn pawn that would be great get
a bit of a money bonus so they keep buy
even more stuff in the next round
Renee's gonna paint at the feet oh my
god
Pasha a nuclear for me
floating dosha hope it pans moe and it
was a literal claymore mine can we
actually see that again please cuz it's
not everyday that you actually get to
see an H she gets three kills like this
they all had full HP as well how yeah
how does it take so much damage this is
a 100 is it double tough elaichi at
exactly the same time it went off
together now those were perfect examples
of well-executed pipe grenade plays but
guys we can't all be a straw --less when
it comes to utility usage in fact most
of us aren't even close and sometimes
you can even say that of the pros I'm
gonna do both of the know about it
you're some of our favorite fails and 20
moments involving grenades from csgo
uber taking a bit of damage all he's
gonna get connected on twice with
minutes down to four HP trying to do
what he can actually get pegged it's a
decoy frag oh oh my god that's the first
time that I've actually seen one live at
a match
Fields is killed over with a decoy
grenade that is huh both these teams are
expected to go through both these teams
mentally would have expected to go
through at the beginning of that round
forever you well because on this
strategy I actually needed two flashes
okay but I didn't had like two flashes I
had the like foreign aids so I destroyed
the name but I didn't expect that and I
didn't know what to say to be honest
they talked about my OneTouch scoodles
coming around the backside a monster
buddy used to find JW while that's
happening sean gares gets cribs and now
products is the only man standing he's
off at the side he's got him Molly this
could be perfect to stop this defuse he
sauces it out there that's gonna slow
things down tries the piyo type
skadoodle will get him and the off have
they got tied they're just gonna see
them bad setup buddy
oh my god cloud 9 what is happening and
the B side is now open for business
mumbles I'll get planet arcane evidence
the last two remaining slimmies already
pushing out here looking for some more
action but making it a 2 versus 2 we
actually could be possible for CLG to go
for this it goes a little bit Restless
let me take that buy it long right to do
the wheel huge Nate though yeah let's
peter down yeah yeah yep that just
happened there's so much thing that just
happened it's such like an important
round to just like a slow kill that was
like an important retake kill and now
it's summit in the 1v1 to try and close
this out again smugly bug be playing it
aggressively no that's no that's good
clutch [ __ ] and flank will close out map
number 116 211 food oh wait what
[Applause]
okay then no what happened
oh no no
oh that is freaks forward leaning back
is Dewey's looking for it more bullets
the wrong move it's time to get he did
with the nade not even though I mean I
guess you can say died to the Molly with
the in her head job Kenny's gonna try
and hold off rain jumping who stops up
the jump that throws Kenny off but not
the noscope and it's down to another 1
vs. 1 1 hp as well than a dog bellowing
bouts in the wrong way an apex hits the
shot with one the nade would have done
it that's gonna be a tough one hero
Shazam trying to get the shot on the
Knights we're trying to go for the jump
shot that's everybody's favorite
mechanics right Oh does he get it again
going for dumped ugly fighting some more
damage but not enough to get a frag as
starting to head back over towards CPL
keep close keeping close to connector
just in case as a flank coming in I
think Freiburg mess up that flashbang
there oh that's terrible
he hit forest on the head and then it
landed behind him and killed him well
guys that's all she wrote for the best
grenade kills fails and funny moments
from csgo now if you want to see more
content like this tell you exactly what
you can do you can nade stack the light
button
Molly the subscribe button and of course
drop a couple decoys in the comment
section and I'll see you next week
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]